from and exchange views with experts in
relations to upcoming revision of the
2cc directive
this revision aims to protect children
better against risk in toys particularly
from chemicals and at the same time to
strengthen the single market for toys
so
I proposed
at first our experts will take the plow
for maximum eight minutes each
so our time is limited
and then
members of the parliament will raise
questions
maximum one minute each and one speaker
for one political group welcome
so and then
our experts will respond to those
questions but all together just nine
minutes
for all the experts
so
I would like to to ask
uh
mocks up their Mr Klaus jergensen expert
from onak the European consumer voice in
standardization to take the floor for
eight minutes please
Mike
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me here to this public hearing
it's a very important issue I am from
the Danish consumer Council and today
I'm representing anik and if you can
change to the second slide please
this is the agenda of today I will talk
a little bit about anec just so you know
who we are but then I will also talk
about different issues in the choice
regulation
next slide please
so this is just to show you what Annex
is all about where a standardization
organization
and where all the European consumers
voice in standardization
I won't go into detail with this but one
of the main issues of anik is to focus
on child safety and toy safety
we sit on a different uh
at safety expert groups and subchemical
groups and we're also of course involved
in the
toys
standardization process
next slide please
so what we basically want to do is to
ensure that the European standardization
and legislation provides the best
protection available for children
because they are the most vulnerable
people that we have here on Earth we
want to protect them even more than we
do the adults of course we have to
protect the adults but the children are
more vulnerable and we have to protect
them as much as we can they are still
developing and we need to protect them
because they evolve and are developing
and any chemicals that they come into
contact with will potentially harm their
development
next slide please
so on this slide I've put down a few of
the examples of what we have found in
the Danish consumer councils we test
toys uh maybe three four times a year
and basically we always find unwanted
chemicals in toys but always we always
find Choice without unwanted chemicals
so this shows that it is actually
impossible impossible to do this
also I want to add that
children are not only exposed to
chemicals from toys but they're also
exposed from other products that they
are surrounded with we did a big test
this spring that showed that 60 of 120
products for children contain chemicals
of concern
and a recent study of personal care
products from children in Denmark
published in contact dermatitis showed
that about 54 percent of all the
cosmetics and makeup for children
contain perfume and of course this is
also something that's addressed in the
choice legislation so what we're saying
is that we need to not only look at the
chemicals in toys but also at the
chemicals that children are exposed to
from other products and if you go into a
toy store you'll probably find makeup
and face paint for children as well
thank you next slide
but to put it shortly we're very
satisfied with the regulation that is
proposed we're very pleased that it's
going to be a regulation and also I
think I speak for the whole NGO
community that is that we are very very
pleased that it has now included
chemicals that can affect the endocrine
system
uh endocrine disrupting chemicals have
been an issue for many years and it's
very good to see that the commission is
actually acting on this and including
this into the protection of children
it's very pleasing to see that all
substances that are now banned for
children under three years of age will
be banned in all choice so this is also
a positive things
there's also a proposal to ban bisphenol
a this is also something we like but
we're also
asking what about the other bisphenols
shouldn't we also ban them
we like to have uh we're very supportive
of the chromatology procedures that have
been set in place and we like the fact
that the companies have to make sure
that the safety assessment also includes
exposure scenarios from other scenarios
of course there are limited uh sorry
sorry there are limited derogations to
be allowed when if ekka approves and so
on but we propose that it should only be
maximum of three years and after three
years we hope that maybe the ones the
company has got the delegation can come
and show they've tried to get rid of
this chemical
uh or somehow show that it's still
impossible so they need to reapply so
the irrigation should only be time
Limited
and finally I would also like to say
that it's it's very good to see that
environmental information should be
available in a digital part of product
passport
next slide please
and the digital passport is of course
important we see it as a very good
supplement to uh the marking on the toy
but a point that we want to stress is
that it should be very easy for the
consumers to assess
this digital passport and of course this
mean that it should be free and it
should also contain
uh the needed information for the
consumers
we're a bit concerned about when it is
to be implemented uh it's not really
clear if it's right away after the the
info after the regulation goes into
enforcement but um
the sooner the better that the digital
passport can be in place the better for
consumers
also we have as I mentioned this about
the derogations and also we think that
the nitrous amines that are now being
banned and some toys should be banned in
all toys
and I would like to mention here a
special Danish position uh we've been
asking for laboring requirements in
Denmark for many years and actually some
companies in Denmark are now labeling
chemical toys such as
slime and also uh
bubble bubble baths I think it's called
um and so labeling would enable
consumers to make a choice out in the in
the store to whether or not they want to
be exposed to these chemicals
next slide please
so connected choice is uh also mentioned
in the in the in the legislation but um
is it good enough and it says something
about that we have to wait because this
has been regulated in other legislation
from the EU but we think it's sort of
similar to the chemicals issue there is
a risk and it's not really in place in
the other legislation some of it is not
even finalized yet so we think we could
also include
the connectivity of toys into the toys
legislation as well
next slide please
and also
it says in the regulation that we have
to focus on noise levels but it's not
really
mentioned at what limit it is and we
prefer to have the limit set in the
standard sorry in the in the legislation
instead of having it done by the
standards
in the standards so
please include also noise levels in the
legislation
uh we're very supportive of the on the
next slide we're very supportive of the
new powers that have been granted to the
European commission especially that they
can now amend and specify certain
provisions and make emergency risks
and also the final slide I think I had
10 seconds the the precautionary
principle is mentioned only in the
recitals let's get it back into the
the legal text so that we can use this
when we want to protect our children
thank you
Let's uh let's take
another speaker at first and then then
we will raise questions and then you
will get uh some time uh to respond so
next speaker will be Mr Christian
Wittenberg
from the European committee for
centralization and the European Network
for technical committee for
centralization
the floor is yours please thank you very
much and thanks for inviting me so I'm
here in my capacity as chairman of the
technical committee that is responsible
for the European standards for toy
safety I'm employed by the LEGO Group
where I head up our department for
product safety and compliance
next slide please
just showing shortly what sen and
senilek are so together with Etsy those
are the three officially recognized
so-called esos and they have 34 members
so another seven countries in addition
to the European member states
next slide please
I also wanted to explain what a
harmonized standard is that is a
standard which is developed by one of
these three esos for example centenelic
Andre mandates or a request from the
European Commission and in the process
all stakeholders are welcome to find
consensus and then publish the standard
once it's published it's sent to the
European commission with a request to
have a reference published and when the
reference is published the standard
gives a presumption of Conformity to the
relevancy marking directive in this case
toys so it's a wonderful tool which
gives access to the internal Market
next slide please
and a little bit of History it's over 40
years ago since we published the first
standard and they have been kept updated
to be state-of-the-art over the years
considering new findings new science new
directives Etc
next slide please
these are the standards that are
presently in place so it's 14 standards
altogether and there are a few in the
making
and you can click once more because I
think that will Mark yes the three first
standards so they are applicable to all
toys while as the other standards will
be applicable for the particular type of
toy so if you produce finger paints you
need to consider that standard in
addition to the first three
so a very broad range of Standards next
slide please
now there are three items that I think
are relevant from a standardization
point of view one is the common
specifications
another one is the digital product
passport and the third one are the
technical changes because all these
might require involvement from
standardization
the first one common specifications is
not something that send and send the
lick are too happy about because we do
consider that standardization should be
the primary roots for harmonized
technical specifications
now if anyhow the common specifications
are introduced they should be introduced
in a horizontal manner we can today see
that the texts are slightly different in
different pieces of regulations or
proposals and we would recommend to use
the Machinery regulation as a blueprint
to ensure that it's applied in the same
manner and only used as a fallback
solution
next slide please
the other one is the digital product
passport and this is currently a work
stream in the high level forum for
European standardization and we do
believe that an important step is to
create the standards that will enable
manufacturers to implement the digital
product passports in a harmonized way
across different regulations so here we
really just conclude that sensenetic is
ready to supply those standards we have
already received the first draft
standardization request from the
commission and I think a second version
is is on its way so that the work can
then get started
and then next slide please if we go to
the technical parts so there have been
changes made to the particular safety
requirements and also to other sections
which will probably need to be addressed
in standards
the first one would be the fact that
warnings can now the word warning can be
replaced with a symbol that will save
packaging from having the word warning
translated into the 23 EU languages but
of course the symbol needs to be
regulated in the details in a standard
when it comes to Mechanical hazards we
can see from the wording that there
might be a need to expand the sound
pressure level requirements that are
present in place to cover also toys that
haven't been designed to emit sound but
that do emit sound
microbiological risks are called out
specifically in the new drafts proposal
or draft regulation
and this is actually something that we
have already started work on
um under an other standardization
requests from the commission so that's
in the making
and we can go to the next slide
and then we come to the more difficult
parts so as we've heard one of the main
changes is indeed the new chemical
requirements where we go from having
certain limit values to relate to to a
complete ban of a couple of thousand
substances
and it's it's difficult right here and
now to assess the need and also the
visibility to create standards that will
support this requirements
because typically a test method would be
supporting uh
compliance with the limit value but when
there is no limit value it becomes a bit
more difficult
so we can see that this will of course
be dependent on what will be covered in
the standardization request from the
European commission but depending on the
scope of that this might be a very large
or a very time consuming task
um so I think we we are not sure what
this means yet but it could well have a
big effect on standardization
there is a mentioning of the need to
protect the psychological the mental
health of children
and we are not sure whether that might
require standards to support how you can
show compliance with the requirements
and then there are a few detailed
wordings where there might be small
editorial changes which will in the end
decide whether or not there is a need
for standards a few examples would be
that we today have to protect children
from harmful electrical shocks the text
presently says in the new regulation
that we need to protect them from
electrical shocks
um also those that are not harmful that
of course would
um be a challenge
um it appears that all warnings will
need to be visible at the point of
purchase while is today only the
warnings that would decide the
consumer's decision to buy the toy
um it also seems that the CE Mark has to
be adjacent to the warnings but these
are things that we think might just be a
matter of how they're worded but
once we know then we will also be able
to Define if standardization will be
needed
next slide please
so just to summarize Sans and the leg
would like to see that standardization
is the primary route to create these
harmonized technical specifications
referring to the success over the 30
years that we've had or 40 actually
we've had the soy safety standards we
foresee a good and close collaboration
with a commission and with other
stakeholders in this work ready to
embrace the future for example the
digital product passport
and then we need to consider once we
know more about what is required by the
standardization process is the
transitional period sufficient to take
that into consideration
thank you
thank you very much next I would like to
ask Minister Han singles from the
European commission to take the floor
place the floor is yours
thank you Mr chair and thank you also to
The Honorable members for having
organized this hearing
the commission proposal on the new toy
safety regulation
is an evolution it's not a revolution
next slide please because we tried to do
is to revise the toast safety rules in a
specific political context first of all
this proposal is a follow-up of the Epi
report that the parliament adopted on
the implementation of the director and
which called for the revision of the
directive
but it's also a follow-up of the
chemical strategy for sustainability
where the commission also committed
itself to strengthen the requirements on
chemicals in consumer products
this proposal is also not coming in
isolation it's coming together with the
revision of the CLP regulation uh the
revision of the reach regulation which
will be tabled by the commission during
the coming months and it also takes into
account the ongoing discussions between
Council and Parliament on the equidizer
for sustainable products regulation
next slide please
so we have revised this uh the current
director if we transformed it in a
regulation as a consequence of the
evolution of the directive uh which
found that most elements of the
directive are still valid the directive
was an efficient tool to ensure the
safety of children and to ensure the
single market for toys
but there were some shortcomings in the
current rules on on toys first of all
being that the directive doesn't
sufficiently protect from all harmful
chemicals especially endocrine
disrupters and most uh other most
harmful substances
[Music]
and though it was necessary to set new
chemical limit values for tours uh
for for children to be put to the mouth
the evolution also found new risks on
data and cyber security that could not
be tackled and also found and as we all
know that there are many non-compliant
choice on the single Market
this proposal is also takes into account
the fitness second chemical solicitation
that the commission published in July
2019 and this was sufficient materials
for us to start revising the directive
entrance format into regulation next
slide please
so
um this proposal is an evolution it's
not a revolution so what we've tried to
take into uh what we've tried to do is
to keep what's function so a number of
elements are almost identical as in the
toy safety directive but we've also made
a number of important changes
uh first one is the broader concept of
safety that we introduced where tourism
is not jeopardize health and safety uh
but that will also cover psychological
well-being and cognitive development
this is an important novelty in this
proposal
so it's part of the general safety
requirement also in the specific safety
requirements will make the number of
important changes
uh there are a few there are not many
changes in the specific safety
requirements on physical flammability
and electrical property and so on the
most important changes are on the
chemical properties because we do
believe that it's important to protect
children against the risks of the most
harmful substances especially endocrine
disruptors there have been many debates
in this Parliament on endocrine
disrupting chemicals here the commission
takes action against the endocrine
disrupting substances by buying them
from the use in toys
next slide please
so the most harmful substances uh will
be preventatively banded choice so this
proposal includes a generic ban On the
Hazardous properties of a substance
so uh Advanced CMS but it's uh already
known but we also intend to ban under
this proposal at the end of quite
disruptive respiratory sensitizers and
substances toxic to a specific organ
the logic always being that children are
the most vulnerable creatures on this
planet and that we need to protect them
much more than we currently do and that
most harmful substances should not be
used in in toys unless
there is a scientific assessment done by
ekka that would Grant a delegation in on
the in limited circumstances
other specific chemicals for chemicals
so we allow adaptation to the toy safety
rules to emerging knowledge of chemical
substances and we impose new limits for
substances on any toy following a
specific assessment based on exposure
and use
and this proposal would then also Grant
the possibility for the commission to
introduce additional restrictions for
other chemicals and toys when pursuant
to a specific assessment they're deemed
to be unsafe
next slide
so this is the essential element safety
elements that we tried to do for
protecting children there are a number
of things that we also will not do so I
have a few minutes because the
parliament also asks for other
amendments for instance on cyber
security
but as we all know there's already
between the reports and between the
evaluation and the proposal there's been
other legislation been adopted in
parallel
I really didn't considered necessary we
even considered as Superfluous to repeat
legislation I always adopted elsewhere
so this proposal that also takes into
account the evolution of the European
legislation since the evaluation was
tabled and since the report of the
parliament was labeled
so ensuring the protection of children
is one of the two main objectives of
this proposal we look very much forward
to the working together with this
community with up in Parliament on uh
ensuring that we still keep a high level
of ambition for protecting children and
in my second intervention I'll talk a
bit more on single Market enforcement
and Level Playing Field for businesses
thank you Mr chair
foreign
thank you ladies and gentlemen panelists
I'm delighted that we're talking uh
about toy safety in this hearing this
afternoon as rapporteur for this subject
is of particular importance to me that
we make this exchange possible because
we benefit from the experience of the
panelists and the expertise of the
panelists is worth its weight in gold
you've all said it's about health
and protection of vulnerable children
this is a top priority ensuring their
health so I would like to start by
thanking the commission
for the new proposal where the toys are
directive is transformed into a
regulation that's what the parliament
wanted
so that is a good starting point and it
was uh stressed in the opinion that that
is felt to be important that alone will
increase toy safety because a union-wide
unified uh application will be insured
and harmonization of legislation
and
also if you
compare the EU to other International
areas toys are still quite high up the
list of products that are registered as
being unsafe in the single Market
particularly uh toys from outside the EU
particularly
through online
trade toys that land pretty much
directly in the children's bedrooms from
outside the EU so it would be important
to address that and my questions are
particularly for Mr Wittenberg from San
elec consent it's about the commission's
proposal and your views of it
and the product passport issue that you
talked about what kind of information
do you think could be contained within
that passport what information would be
necessary because we hear from
manufacturers that having to put too
much information in the passport can
lead to falsification so we don't want
to throw the baby out with the bath
water and then there's the problem of
mental health you briefly mentioned this
and I'd like to hear uh what you think
about that um
because
it's something that is not legally
defined so what kind of Standards did
you have in mind there
and also we've just been dealing with
the packaging files in other committees
and the packaging industry are telling
us
that a lot of the information is uh not
useful or Superfluous so we have a
conflict of interest so the question is
what is necessary what needs to be
stated on the packaging and what needs
to be stated on the toy itself and what
needs to be included
in the list of instructions in the
packaging and then you also talked about
compatibility with other proposed pieces
of legislation this is probably very
important the DSA product safety cyber
security rules they all need to be
aligned so perhaps you could say
something on that
thank you very much the next I would
like to ask Christian Salter Moser from
smt group to take the floor please thank
you very much chair and I will speak in
Danish because I have Danish translation
today so thanks
for goal presentation
thank you chair and thank you for the
good presentations about this regulation
toys is
one of the things that we have evaluated
year after year so we can protect our
children that's very important so my
praise to the commission because I think
this is a really good Point of Departure
to be able to protect our children even
better
I do have a couple of questions
which will tie in nicely with
um other panel
participants questions because Klaus
Johnson says that the precautionary
principle is only there in the recital
why we have always wanted it to be part
of the legislative text because
it is something that shows what we want
where legislation might be slightly
ambiguous so we want to make it quite
clear that producers have thought about
the precautionary principle from the
beginning so maybe the commission could
tell me why it's not there from the very
beginning
and then there's the preoccupation from
industry and the other side who say that
it's difficult to
combine this with the rules in the
chemical area
it can be difficult to avoid any trace
of a chemical
so they would like to rewrite parts of
the legislation to get a more precise
wording is that a real concern and
what could we do so we don't expose our
children to more chemicals
but let me repeat I'm really happy with
this point of departure I'm happy that
we are focusing on endocrine disruptors
and chemicals
and finally about Mental Health
I think it's really good that
we think about it here we do in other
legislation like the Digital Services
Act
but how would we Define it I would like
to hear what the commission says about
that
but I think it's a really good idea
don't understand me wrong how can we do
it though
so I look forward to working with this
in Parliament in the final months we
have thank you thank you very much next
I would like to ask
to take the floor please
foreign
English and I've two topics to the
commission thanks for the presentation
um
um on when it comes to the Ia act and
children with disabilities so two groups
um when we have the toy safety
regulation does not regulate digital
aspects concerning toys and therefore it
does not deal with cyber security data
protection or privacy of connected toys
in the commission series such risks are
addressed in relevant legislation such
as VI act and radio equipment directive
however the inclusion of toys in the Ia
act will depend on the definition of the
AI system
which is still under negotiation as you
know and as well as a qualification of
toys as high risks products
under the current tax of the Ia act not
all toys will be considered high risks
but only toys that undergo third-party
confirmation assessment so the very
detailed question so just a few of them
that means that only certain toys would
be classified as high risk
thereby ensuring more protection to kids
While others would not
this would be conceptually a warped toys
are a particular problematic category as
a whole
since they are used by a vulnerable
group kids under 14. and now on the top
list the most modified unsafe and
non-compliant products in the safety
gate
we would like to know from you dear
commission man stakeholders is a panel
that you think about this major loophole
which would be very difficult to address
for my view in the negotiation the Ia
negotiation and the second part
additionally we notice that the Adaptive
toys for children with disabilities have
no place
in that proposal
despite having been brought up as
important point in the any report I'm
the shadow reporter for the green Seer
adaptive toys allow children with
disabilities the opportunity have
experience and access
and may I ask here to commission why
Provisions for adaptive toys have not
been included in the proposal for toy
safety regulation
thanks for your attention and looking
forward for your answer thank you
thank you very much next I would like to
ask on Sophie Pelletier to take the
floor please
thank you
and thank you for these explanations
now toys
are extremely important because as we've
been saying for since
the beginning of the meeting these are
products for our children I've got to go
back to what I believe Christel was
saying about the precautionary principle
it's important that they be covered by
this now about the passport
the product passport I think is a good
idea basically but I think that it has
to be thought through
um in in a very inclusive fashion now
Catherine was just talking about
children with disabilities but there are
children who have parents with
disabilities so that passport shouldn't
just be a QR code it should really
be identified with a product which can
be fully used
that you referred to chemical properties
you referred to endocrine disruptors
these are crucial issues we're talking
about the health not just of our
children but Public Health in general I
think that these products these
disruptors have to disappear totally
from toys and let's be honest we can see
that some member states are quite simply
blocking a ban on these products and yet
we we cannot negotiate when talking
about health there's no compromise
possible if we allow for waivers we'll
have to
be very careful indeed because waivers
for me are tantamount to just leaving
the door open and letting
dangerous products remain on the market
we simply won't be reacting we have to
regulate composition to ensure that our
toys are safe and healthy the safety and
and
health of our children and adults
um video games and addiction for
instance that that's another issue all
of these matters should be taken into
account for our future Generations thank
you thank you very much and now I would
like to ask our experts to take the
floor nine minutes all together three
minutes each
who will be the first one
Mr Christian Wittenberg please the floor
is yours thank you I'll try to address
the various questions although I will
stick to a standardization point of view
I think I need to highlight that the
fact that there are unsafe toys on the
market which are also registered in in
the safety gate system is not
necessarily solved by having stricter
requirements it's a matter of making
sure that those toys comply with the
present toy safety standards and and
that is of course a problem that we see
these products on the market that do not
fulfill the safety standards so I think
that's a different topic it's more about
Market surveillance
um there was a question around alignment
between different
regulations and the point I made there
was to ensure that the way the common
specifications are worded in the
different regulations or proposal is
uniform so that it can be horizontally
clear under which conditions common
specifications can be used and withdrawn
uh when it comes to the digital product
passports and what can or should be
included
um as far as I understand today the
requirements in the toy safety directive
is in a way to replace the present EU
decoration of Conformity but also to add
information on chemicals of concern
however those are yet to be defined in
the Echo design for sustainable products
regulation so we don't know exactly what
requirements there are and there's also
an opening to say that in the future
additional items might be added to the
digital product passport under the toy
safety regulation so I think it's still
a bit in the making
um when it comes to the standards that
would support the digital product
passports I think it's about putting
systems in place so that there is a tool
for manufacturers to to implement this
the present requirement is to have
indeed a
could be a QR code could also be other
instruments and when you scan it you get
access to the digital product passport
and and that of course
could be solved by each company but
standards could help them to find a
platform to do that
was also a question about the
psychological and mental and cognitive
health of children
and if you look at the other Hazard
categories that are addressed so
chemical mechanical electrical
hygiene
radioactivity hazards flammability they
have
specific or particular safety
requirements linked to them
based on which standards can be
developed
for the statements around psychological
and mental health being there aren't any
supporting particular safety
requirements which makes it difficult
today to see exactly how and if
standards could be developed to support
this
thank you
and our next experts who will be close
here Arkansas please of the voice yours
thank you and thank you for all the good
questions from Bay Oak's point of view
we're still negotiating with our members
and listening to their input to finding
out what they actually want to be
included in our position but as for the
digital project
passport it's it's important for us that
the information is available on the
packaging or at least in in the
all the safety information and all the
the warnings and and preferably also
chemicals of concern because then the
consumers can make an informed Choice
when in the shop and they can be guided
by uh ngos that that help them
choose the right kinds of toys of course
we prefer that the chemicals are not in
there at all but as the regulation is
right now it's open up for derogations
and so on so if there are derogations
let's put them on the packaging so the
consumers can see that they're actually
there
um and we like I said in my presentation
the precautionary principle is is key
here the children are are most
vulnerable
[Music]
and we need to protect them as much as
we can and like I said we are not only
exposed from endocrine disruptors from
toys but also from the food we eat from
the air we breathe from the the
surroundings that we have around us and
this is maybe the first
legislation that really takes this into
account so
um we need to be uh very careful with
our children and the precautionary
principles should definitely be in the
legal text not only in the recitals
um
I think it's interesting to to look uh
at the issue about children with
disabilities and also because
if parents have disabilities maybe it's
not so easy to use a digital passport
um and I think this is something that we
have to discuss at anik as well
um and one of the things that we've been
we've been talking about is that it's a
QR code enough do every
person on this Earth have a telephone
that they can scan this information
maybe there should be something
available in the store that can help
consumers if they have to scan a QR code
so
we need to look into to how we can make
this as easy as possible for for for
consumers when they're out there
um
yes I think that's I think that's it for
now
thank you and now I would like to ask
Hans Ingles from the European commission
to take the floor please
thank you very much unfortunately I have
all the F3 minutes I would like to have
33 minutes but this is unfortunately not
possible so I'll try to address as many
comments as possible possibly a bit too
short first of all I'll take them out
packaging and packaging waste we're
taking in that proposal also into
account but we took the commission
proposal as a basis for our
our toy safety proposal the packaging
and packaging waste proposal all the uh
relates to the composition of the
packaging as such and the waste streams
while what we try to cover is the
warnings and the information to parents
or grandparents or friends who buy toys
for children so this warnings need to be
in the package because what we want to
correct is uh the information gap
between the manufacturers all the
information and the parents who don't
necessarily have the information but
very often in an emotional moment
together with the children want to buy a
product and so they need to have the
full information on for whom is a pilot
and how could it be used and that needs
to be in the packaging because it
determines the purchase decision
if you put it on the product itself a
lot of the information will will get
lost because the child will already be
in position of of the product
for the cognitive well-being and the
mental health there we relied on the
concept that was developed by The Who
as as a broader concept of safety
because we do believe that we need to
consider this as a on an international
basis
and this is part of the general safety
requirement so uh so that we need to act
against emerging risks
um and we do believe that this is an
important novelty
um I recognize the challenges for the
standardization bodies also on how to
develop this and I think that this is
something that we will all have to learn
together on purpose we did not Define it
so precisely but you will see also
similar language in the General Public
Safety regulation which was recently
adopted which we also talking to a
company because it will partly apply
here to choice and so we didn't want to
copy because uh this is this is this is
not allowed we also took into account
the digital Service Act which we're also
not repeating here same thing with the
radio equipment directive it's there's
no point in putting all the other
requirements again and repeat it in this
legislation manufacturers should ensure
that the choice that they put a place in
the market comply with all the existing
rules
it's true that also for a number of
issues the negotiations with the
Parliament and Council are still ongoing
for instance on cyber security and you
made very valid comments about the AI
act we also aware and therefore we would
like to see how the negotiations with
Parliament and Council was evolved and
then possibly tackle any remaining
issues here in the toy safety proposal
I understand also that the digital
product passport is something that we
addressed during the second part of this
session uh
um for chemicals there's indeed we try
to be stringent but we also have a
traces uh provision and that allows
certain cases none this because some
traces are unavoidable and we've got the
provisional unavoidable traces in the
next two precautionary principle is for
us very important and therefore we also
put it in the recital because we we
should read the entire text together
recitals also have a meaning they
explain why we're doing certain things
and our the precautionary principle is
in the first instance something that
needs to be applied by European
legislator by the Council of parliament
in the commission because we have to
apply it and we cannot will always rely
on businesses to apply and to be
familiar with the precautionary
principle and we try to do this in the
proposal I try to conclude
uh and then there's the final statement
is also um I've heard that tools are
problematic as a whole it's not entirely
correct and we should cover this to to
in the General Session it's true that
there are many non-compliant choice on
on the market that doesn't mean that
tourists as such as a category
um is from or that there's a fundamental
problem with the tourist rules the
fundamental problem and this is
something that we should discuss
afterwards is that number of people a
number of businesses are not applying
those and this is a major problem it's a
major problem for all of us and in the
first instance is for children if we
allow that unsafe Choice are being
placed on the market toys that do not
comply with the rules then it's time to
take action and I hope that we can have
a good discussion here
um on uh on on this during the second
session sorry for uh yeah thank you very
much I would like to thank all the
speakers who took the floor in the first
panel and now when we can continue with
our panel and I would like to ask Mr
Catherine van Grace uh General from Toy
industries of Europe to take the law
please deploy is yours thank you very
much Mr chair good afternoon own thank
you for having me here at tie toy
industries of Europe we represent those
toy makers who care really care about
the safety of their toys so of course
we're keen to contribute to the debate
so that toys will indeed be safe but
also fun and affordable one of the main
purposes of the regulation is to ensure
that there are no obstacles to the free
movement we welcome this very much free
movement of toys is very important for
us and in the past we did have sometimes
obstacles because of different
interpretations by different National
authorities and I have to give credit
and thanks here to the European
commission and especially to digi grow
because they then usually would smooth
over those differences and that's why
also we welcome the change from a
directive into a regulation because it
will make all of this much easier
the proposal should also lead to a
greater level of safety as well as legal
certainty certainty and a Level Playing
Field for industry here I have to say we
have some concerns we fear that a number
of elements in The Proposal will not
provide us with legal certainty and most
certainly not level out the playing
fields I would like to add that we have
not seen toys that comply with the
current TSD which really pose a safety
risk
I'd like to explain some things about
toys and about Manufacturing in the Toy
Market so that you may better understand
our fears
I have an example of a characteristic of
the Toy Market
um this is a real safe toy made by a
reputable manufacturer this is the
unsafe version of it there are a lot of
unsafe toys about no one disagrees about
this and unsafe toys have nothing to do
with reputable companies they are made
by toy companies who have no intention
of playing by the rules their tours do
not comply with the current directive
and they will not comply with the new
regulation and that is the field in
which we play and which needs to be
leveled out
another characteristic is that we are a
relatively small sector so to our
suppliers we are really small fish and
if the materials for our toys need to be
more pure than those for other consumer
products they will either need to
provide us with Alternatives or they
will need to do more testing to
guarantee the Purity demand for this
will not be high enough if it remains
just toy specific it will only be
interesting if they can charge a big
extra cost
now I I I was thinking of an example we
have a member a small member who used to
sell napkins like these in a box with
paints so that children can decorate
them and when the TSD rules came into
Force none of his suppliers were willing
to provide proof that the napkin was
safe when it was a toy so they and it
would have been as a small company it
would have been too costly for them to
do the testing themselves so they had to
discontinue the product
it feels to us that it will become even
more difficult to sell safe toys instead
of it becoming difficult to sell unsafe
toys you also have to ask yourself if
it's so difficult for toy makers to
prove that their products are safe what
will it be like for Market survey and so
you have to check if this is all true
will they really have the resources for
this
and of course we understand that we have
to jump higher we have to do better than
many other sectors exactly because of
who we are but quite a few elements in
The Proposal will not make the toy safer
they may make it Greener and we also
want Greener toys but then we need to be
part of a bigger demand otherwise our
toys will either disappear or become too
expensive while the crap unsafe versions
of them continue to exist
so really Greening toys should be
handled through horizontal legislation
just to give one example we agree with
the ban on endocrine disruptors that are
dangerous for human health but abandoned
endocrine disruptors that are not good
for the environment needs to be dealt
with through horizontal legislation
now like many other sectors a lot of our
products are also sold online
unfortunately a large proportion of toys
sold online are sold by those people I
mentioned earlier the ones who have no
intention to follow the rules I think
everyone agrees this and the commission
proposes the digital product passport to
tackle this we're also counting on the
DSA the Customs regulation and the
general product safety regulation to
tackle some of the problems but there is
one remaining blind spot none of those
pieces of legislation can really do
anything about and that's the tsunami of
toys that come from non-eu operators and
where no one else in the EU has any
responsibility we would really like to
see the regulation recognize the
channels that make those sales possible
as importers
it sounds like a very big ask but it's
the only way that it can be meaningfully
addressed the volume is too big to bet
on markets away and solving it we need
prevention
I just mentioned the DPP to be very
honest we have a lot of questions still
about it and how it will work exactly
but one thing we do know is it will not
be the miracle cure that will fight
unsafe toys on the market if you can
fake a toy you can fake a toy passport
and even those without a passport will
for the most go unnoticed especially if
they're sold through online platforms
that carry no responsibility of checking
anything
the final point I want to raise is the
timing it takes a minimum of 18 months
to bring a new idea for from an idea to
a toy on the market the proposal has a
13-month transition period I know 13
months sounds like a lot but subtract 18
months and we only have one year left we
fear that will not be enough
especially seeing as the digital product
a passport still has a lot that needs to
be decided the work on the standards
that we will need to apply the
regulation can only start once the
regulation has been adopted any
exemption requests for the safe use of
some substances will need to be launched
and then we'll take a probably a minimum
of a year so really we are going to need
a lot more time another point in terms
of time is that the proposal says that
once the regulation has been enforced
for 12 months all toys that comply with
the old rules will need to be taken off
the market
in practice that means that we will have
to destroy these toys
this makes absolutely no sense not from
a safety point of view and definitely
not from a sustainability point of view
so we really are asking for a much
longer period and
um for for those older toys so compliant
toys to be able to remain on the market
I think in summary I would like to ask
you the European Parliament to ensure
that it becomes easier to sell safe toys
and more difficult to sell unsafe toys
and if the new regulation accomplishes
that I think both consumers and
businesses alike will be very happy
thank you very much
thank you very much and next I would
like to ask Mr Florence
to take the Vlog from and she is
representing Belk the European consumer
officers please thank you and good
afternoon ladies and gentlemen
um I'm definitely delighted to be here
and to be sharing books perspective on
the toy safety regulation to start with
and we can immediately go to the next
slide please I wanted to stress that we
really welcome The Proposal that has
been published by the European
Commission because from a preliminary
analysis
um we really believe that it directly
addresses the problem of children
exposure to dangerous chemicals and it
has also the potential to address many
of the concerns that were raised during
the refit evaluation but also many of
the recommendations that were included
in the initiative report of the European
element
so in this context we really call for a
swift adoption of the the position of
the European Parliament and of the
council because at least in our
perspective they are only
um minor aspects that needs to be
improved
now if we move on to the next slide
please before sharing more of our
recommendations in order to strengthen
the single Market I wanted to illustrate
what are our concerns from a consumer
perspective and to do so I'll use one
figure one example and one literal story
so the figure of 318 is the number of
alerts about Dentures toys that have
been already made by market savings
authorities since the beginning of this
year that's quite a big number
considering also that it's probably only
the tip of the iceberg
what you see in the middle of the slide
is actually an example of a toy that was
removed from the market and for which an
alert was placed in February and at
least until yesterday
this was still available online on
platforms like Amazon without any
warning about the risks or the problems
that this costs in in the past and the
little story is actually
um about a research that our Dutch
colleagues uh Continental Bond conducted
this summer they started a fake
dropshipping website and then they
started to buy on AliExpress products
including toys that they had previously
identified on the safety gate and with
the same a couple of simple tricks they
were able to see or Convent all the
verification mechanisms and procedures
on platforms like Amazon again and
bold.com and to sell these products to
Consumers so just to say that we are
highly concerned by the very big number
of non-compliant and dangerous toys that
are still available on the market
and moving to the next slide please in
order to address this issue the toy
safety regulation
proposes to I mean mainly tackle this
issue through the introduction of a
digital passport
on on this we believe in the theory that
it's a good development because it will
certainly help the
the authorities to check product or
compliance information in a more let's
say systematic or immediate way however
how the tool will function in practice
how it will be implemented remains to be
seen and in this context we really call
for safeguards to be insured against the
fact for example that the information
could be incorrect or outdated or even
fake
what we consider important in this
context is also to make sure that on top
of the documents checks there are also
enough product checks because we don't
consider this to be the same and
consequently the resources of national
markets events authorities should be
increased not only the human resources
but also from a financial and Technical
point of view in order for them to use
the DPP but also to perform more checks
on on products
last point on the DPP and this has
already been mentioned in in this
hearing we believe that the access to
the DPP should be free for consumers and
also easy
and that also the processing of personal
data should be strictly limited to what
is necessary
to provide the information to Consumers
now what we are afraid of and we can
move to the next slide please
um we fear that the DPP won't be enough
to tackle the problems of online sales
and here we will come with exactly the
same recommendations that we voiced
during the negotiations on the Digital
Services Act and the General Public
Safety regulation meaning that we should
make sure to Define online marketplaces
as economic operators that they should
require to comply with more obligations
and that there should also be a
possibility to help to hold them liable
in case there is no over economic
operator in the supply chain that can be
identified or that can take appropriate
action
um last slide please
we have also
um more recommendations to further
strengthen the single market and all
together the enforcement of legislation
and the level of consumer protection
I'll maybe skip the first three points
because they have been mentioned by the
speakers of the first panel but I would
like to insist on the fact that for what
concerned smart toys so toys that can
connect to the Internet or that includes
artificial intelligence we we consider
it important to require third party
certification otherwise we risk a major
loophole considering what's being
negotiated currently in the Cyber
resilience act and act for the
artificial intelligence Act
um what we also consider important from
a single market and legislation
enforcement perspective is to include
more specific criteria for the
legibility and visibility of warnings
and to make sure not to confuse
consumers with different pictograms
because as far as I we we see in the
text there is this possibility for
manufacturers to use different ones
while we will require here to be clear
and to have a standardized pictogram
I'm still in a view not to confuse
consumers we advise to relegate the CE
marking to the technical file
and
um we also believe that this revision is
an occasion to create a legal basis for
the creation of a European debt database
on accidents and injuries
on the transitional period I think here
we disagree with tie it's not a surprise
but we would like to see these
significant significantly reduced
to conclude I I wanted to say that in
order for this proposal to be a success
it will also need to be backed by an
ambitious reform of the EU Customs thank
you
thank you and once again I would like to
ask on Singles to take the four please
thank you very much Mr chair
it's waiting for my
we can already move to the next slide
so as we all know and I think there we
all agree that there are too many
non-compliant products non-compined
choice on the market uh do you slow it
with uh non-compliant Choice which means
that there are toys that do not
um comply with the current rules and
which have been found by market
surveillance authorities it's on top of
the categories on the safety gate and if
you see if you look at the data from the
markets available is 43 of the choice
subjects to in-depth investigations my
mind surveillance authorities I don't
complied so there's an enormous problem
of businesses not applying the rules at
the moment
this is a risk for everybody first
instance is a risk for children because
they are exposed to products
which contain dangerous chemicals which
also have other risks that we shouldn't
underestimate especially choking risks
if you look at the Rapids at the safety
gate you see that the number of risks
which are now covered
but also a problem for European industry
uh because it endangers the
competitiveness of all those businesses
and especially the smes which would have
utmost to comply with the rules to
respectables to apply rules and these
rules are not not easy because we have a
high protection of uh
high-level protection for children not
unless they do the efforts a number of
people don't do the efforts they make
the easy profits easy gains they get a
lot of money and they put the risk to uh
our children to our grandchildren this
is something that we should all avoid I
don't think that there can be any
discussion about this now the question
is how next slide is
yeah we have taken into account the
existing tools which have been
extensively discussed here in the first
instance there's a there's a market
surveillance regulation but there's also
the Digital Services act which has been
discussed many times in this committee
and it also deserve a product safety
regulation as you know and it's
explained in the recital six and there's
also an entire several provisions on
online sales in general public safety
regulation that also applies to tourists
so therefore again we should not
reinvent the wheel it already exists it
already applies we expanded him inside
the six and we should not re-include it
again in the uh Toy safety proposal
we're not going to reopen the digital
Service Act of General product safety
regulation we respect the decision of
the legislator and we want to be here
specific rules on tours
we think that most of the non-compliant
toys come from outside the EU therefore
um we would like to rely on something
totally new because we all know that we
need more Market surveillance we all
know that we need more Customs controls
therefore what we'd like to do is to
rely on something which is totally new
is a connection of digital product
passport with customs in other words
there should be automated controls at
the external borders we replace the
current Declaration of Conformity by the
digital product password one in one out
on the basis of the digital product
passport which is modeled on the basis
of the of the echo design for
sustainable products regulation on which
we also see viping and other commission
proposals there's a link with the data
carrier that fixed to the tool which
contains the compliance information
which is directly accessible to Market
events and Customs authorities so
products toys that will be placed on the
on the EU Market need to be registered
in a registry and then there will be
automative controls to software at
Customs now if you look at Customs
nowadays there is this system of
verification is fairly simple fairly
primitive and relies also on the Customs
authorities and if they're having a
container it works for instance under
the container with toys you can imagine
which ones will get priority
so here what we like to do is to customs
control because everybody who Imports
the toy into the EU must fill out the
customs declaration and there's a reform
of the Customs code already ongoing
we've got
um
we've we've got specific legislation on
automated Customs control I would like
to put it all together it's new it's
revolutionary but we do think that we'll
do the trick again new provisions of the
same Provisions GPR including in the toy
safety proposal repeating what already
been adopted by this committee a while
ago another uh for us don't add any
value what we need to do is protect
children what we need to do is also
ensure a fair internal market for tour
manufacturers and especially for smes
and we do think that the digital product
password will be the
the primary tool for doing this
we would be more optimistic than our
colleagues from the notorious industry
on this because if this is up and
running we do believe that it will make
a difference
and it will also frighten a lot of
people who are being outside the EU to
sell their products in the EU because
they will see that they have to fill all
this out in the custom Declaration of
art to do much more work to put these
products on the market
next slide please
this goes hand in hand with stronger
Market surveillance and as you know this
Market surveillance regulation also was
adopted in 2019 uh so Margaret
surveillance authorities should check
toys on the market there's a safeguard
close procedure where the commission can
decide in case of disagreement between
Market defense authorities because
Market surveillance authorities can
disagree on a specific product and
that's of the commission to decide but
also a novelty is that the commission
now itself
has a possibility according to proposal
to take measures against tourists that
present a risk
which is also something totally new
which would allow us ex-official to
intervene if we think that
there's a problem with the non-complato
finally also we should not forget the
article 4 of the market surveillance
regulation also specifically applies to
tourists and obliges
to have a responsible person in the EU
for choice
which allows us to pass to the next
slide
which was so you know all in all we do
believe that all these Provisions
strengthen the enforcement of the toy
safety rules that these Provisions will
make a big difference
um especially we have strong confidence
that the digital product passport and
automated custom control will solve many
problems will not solve all problems but
we also do not believe there's any
system in this world that cannot be
falsified but we do think that if you
put
um if you try to be as severe as
possible we can solve the problem of
non-compliant products together thank
you
thank you very much and now we have time
for questions and once again Mario
balchman please just one minute
we had um
thank you colleagues you emphasize in
the second panel of the hearing that our
goal is the highest standard of
protection for children and that was
underlined and they're free and
destroying the free movement toys in the
EU and it we we talk about the toy
industry then we should all be clear
that 99 of firms in this sector are smes
and the majority of those businesses are
in fact very small now this aspect
shouldn't be a low side of when we come
to propose rules and I want to get
something off my chest here because you
you mentioned a figure about who is this
43 of uh unsafe products that are toys
and of those that most of those come
from third countries
so the aid for smes
oh to help them cope with the
administrative burden and to be able to
produce these uh products to have enough
of them in the internal market then we
will have this third country producers
who are circumventing our rules and
selling their products in the internal
markets and they'll be squeezing
producers from the internal Market out
of the market
so I think we have to think very hard
about how we're going to uh
okay our controls and ensure that we
foil those who are far away and who
have no concerns
about selling dangerous products which
local producers can't uh
wouldn't dare to do so
we have to think about Market
surveillance and their necessary
Personnel we have to talk about boosting
the human resources which which is of
course a matter for the member states
and in terms of product safety we had to
call on member states to do the
necessary
in their own interest to to provide the
necessary resources because it's no
secret that in some
ports a lot of controls are carried out
aren't containers and no there's none at
all now and
these we must make it difficult to
circumvent the rules or else there'll be
no deterrent effect so that is a point
that I believe
that we need a system where the rules
are
supervised enforced or else will be
worth nothing so I I would like to thank
all the members of the panel and I think
during the concert the uh pressing of
the dossier will be coming back to some
of them to take the floor please
sure
um from a first reading of the proposal
I'm glad to notice several positive
Elements which are responding to the
parliament's report of February
2022 on which we work together with many
colleagues and it seems that it's trying
to solve some of the main concerns about
the current directive
I have several considerations but I will
limit myself obviously for time
constraints to a couple of questions
first of all one of the shortcomings of
the directive was on the enforcement
side
as it only contained a general
obligation
to the member states to perform a market
surveillance when we approve the
parliament report on the implementation
of the directive the market surveillance
regulation I just started to apply now
it has been two years and I would like
to ask the commission whether in their
assessment they see an improvement in
Market surveillance activities and in
particular in the coordination and
exchange among member states
um these also leads me to a second
consideration and question this time to
the representative of Belk the addition
of the digital product passport seems a
valuable one but only for its clear
reference to sustainability not only for
that but also for the key role it might
have to ensure a swift enforcement of
the regulation in customs checks
however I've noticed that this role has
come to the expense of a strengthened
third-party Conformity assessment which
seemed to enjoy a rather positive
assessment in the explanatory statement
and which was for many including my
political group a clear need for such a
sensitive class of products is the role
of the digital product passport enough
in your opinion to guarantee that only
safe toys will circulate in the EU
Market thank you very much
thank you and next I would like to ask
about to take the floor please thank you
chair I want to thank Our Guest for
taking their time for this debate and
for sharing their perspective on the
single Market of four toys I understand
that this sector is evolving and
changing along with the request for
modern toys for interactive toys but I
also know that the European
manufacturers of toys are mostly smaller
and micro Enterprises which makes it
quite difficult for them to keep up with
the change of the legislation at
European level in different sectors that
are affecting their work like the
chemicals the software the cyber
security to the name just a few still
there is still a request traditional
toys for traditional materials for
Simplicity I would like to understand
from the industry represent and
representatives what are the main
impediments for the migrant small
companies become truly European economic
actors to my manufacture their toys in
one country and sell them all over the
European Union what should we do change
for an artisan toy producer from Finland
to be able to easily sell his toys in
Spain or any other countries thank you
foreign
next I would like to ask on the Sofi
beltier to take the floor please
thank you chairman and thank you to The
Experts I agree with what bioca said is
the responsibility of the platforms and
the manufacturers and I think that is
the angle that we should be seeing this
subject from we were talking about data
bases on accidents before it was the
left that was calling for that in the
past and I believe that that would give
us a better snapshot of the dangerous
nature of some of these products and
finally here again I agree
when the Customs code is reviewed
in the new future if we don't want a
product to get in the first gate is
customs
so what we need is not just a a digital
passport we need people the Customs
officers we say that we want to
digitalize everything but what we really
need is real people on the ground boots
on the ground we need these Customs
agents they are the ones that can stop
these products from getting in because
there are limits to digital tools so for
this to work and I hope this will be in
the code
it's a question more for the commission
but I hope that you're going to put more
Customs boots on the ground that's the
way to stop these products getting in
thank you and now I would like to ask
Martin look regards to take the floor
please
thank you and I'll I'll address you in
in Danish just to warn you
um
first of all let me apologize for coming
in late I don't know if this question
has been asked before
so there's a danger that I repeat
something but I'll just ask anyway
my group
is of course happy
that we now have a regulation instead of
a directive
that's what I wanted to say first there
are many good ideas in the new proposal
but
does that really handle the obstacle
before us
producers have now asked how we handle
third countries
so that's my question to the commission
I apologize if I repeat a question
that's been said
if we have the challenge here that third
parties third countries are skewing
competition
because they don't live up to the rules
I don't think
that the proposal even with the
regulation here gives us a complete
answer
the commission said that we won't be
able to avoid
um anyone scamming but do you think
this is not a very big challenge in
importers and responsibility and
time to give some answers who wants to
be the first one
yes please uh Mr Han singles please
thank you very much and thank you also
for your general support for the uh for
the proposal
um
we focus very much here on enforcement
and rightly so because enforcement is is
a very important item
we do believe that software will add a
lot of value
um as we all know in our daily lives all
the new I.T systems very much help us
and help us become more efficient to
help us to become more productive
and we do believe and we do deeply
believe that the digital passport will
make a difference
uh there will probably never been a
proposal which covers so much
enforcement and Market surveillance as
this one and we try to cover everything
and without repeating what's already
done in the Digital Services act or
without repeating what the general pilot
safety regulation if you look into the
impact assessment you will see that the
we try to assess the efficiency gains
also for markets events authorities and
Customs authorities if the digital
public passport would be operational and
if then we go to the cost EU custom
single window system the two things will
be connected then automatically there
would be an efficiency against for
Market surveillance authorities in other
words there would be efficiency against
but as that would vary between 10 and 20
percent in other words all the time that
market surveillance authorities and
Customs officers now spend on controls
and very often very primitive controls
they could then easily spend on all the
other controls the most substantive
controls on products entering the market
because the software itself will already
identify
problems and importers that usually do
not comply with the product or uh with
the rules or products that do not comply
with rules it will be an additional
hurdle for products entering the EU that
do not comply with the rules
and for us we do believe after total
impact assessment because we've been
Consulting everybody on possible Miracle
Solutions but there are the miracle
Solutions so we have to rely on a number
of in
existing systems we do believe that the
digital product passport is a novelty
that will make a difference
there was also a question on our
experience with the market service
authorities we've seen also a major
difference in practice since the markets
Affairs regulation started applying
there have been many more Market
surveillance activities and they are
also much more coordinated because one
of the troubles in Europe with Market
surveyors is that all Market
surveillance authorities in the past
used to working on Ireland now there's a
network wherever in which they
coordinate there's also more support by
the single Market program there are
stronger rules in working together there
are certain certain presumptions if a
project is found unsafe in one member
State there will be unsafe another
member states so the market surveillance
regulation as such makes a difference
commission is now working on the
evaluation of the functioning of article
4 which is a specific provision which
obliges manufacturers which obliged
people which are not established to have
a responsible person in the EU and that
evaluation will be available
um normally next year
thank you very much
thank you
Mr Lawrence ponzano please yes thank you
um on the question whether the DPP will
be enough to pre prevent the or limit
the exposure of consumers uh to unsafe
toys we believe that it can make a
positive contribution of course
um but as I said during my statement
because the information could be
outdated or could be also fake
we we call for safeguards to be put in
place so that what is in the DPP uh
actually is is valid information
uh and in in this context we think that
in order to limit also the number of
non-compliant toys that are available on
the market
we should go for a more third-party
certification again to start with
connected toys and also expand that to
more these categories and finally
without putting more obligations on
online marketplaces we believe that
there will always be an issue with the
resources and the work that markets and
authorities need to perform so we really
count on on this opportunity and and the
revision of the toy safety directive to
make sure that online marketplaces can
prevent exam day products that are
non-compliant not to be available online
and then maybe to react
to a few comments that have been made on
the fact that most of them
businesses that are toy uh in in the toy
sector are smes we firmly believe that
safety should not be depend depending on
the size of companies like it should not
depend on the sales channels through
which consumers buy their toy whether in
High Street stores or online
and what can certainly help Market
surveillance but also the work of
standard standardizers is to have more
data on injury and accidents that are
caused by toys but also by other
products and having a common methodology
here would really help
um on the fact that digitalization
digitalization sorry has uh limits yes
indeed and what a concrete illustration
that
um we are
um considering here is that because the
DPP will probably increase the number of
alerts
um by Customs to their National
counterparts to Market surveillance
authorities and there will be a
challenge with the deadline that has
been set in the market surveillance
regulation According to which Market
savings authorities need to react within
four working days
um so we really call for safe cars to be
put in place and of course for more
resources uh to better equip markets of
insecurities thank you
thank you and now I would like to ask
Miss Catherine One race to take the
floor please thank you
um I'm grateful to Mrs wellsman for
mentioning that our sector does indeed
consist or our companies are 99 smes I
wasn't sure that I had mentioned that in
my own intervention and thank you also
to the several um speakers in the
committee for uh urging uh the member
states also to do the necessary and not
to forget about human resources in
Market surveillance
um we do think that's very important
um and then with regard to the very
specific question in terms of you know
small manufacturers being able to sell
throughout Europe
um we do have
um companies that used to be small
manufacturers in that are real um you
know European examples basically we have
ravensberger Schleich SCS creative
symbodike and of course Lego also
initially started as a small company
um I think if you are a small
manufacturer of toys in Finland and you
are able to sell your toys in Finland
you should be able to sell them
throughout the European Union because we
have a single market and actually in
recent times it has not been that it's
not been because of safety rules
auditory safety narrative that they see
the or the interpretation that the
single Market was fragmented but more
um through different National member
states asking for environmentally
environmental measures I'm talking about
the packaging and packaging waste
measures I know now this is being
handled but this has actually really
caused for some of our members of
fragmentation of their Market which is a
shame I often think I think it's still
this year the 30th anniversary of the
single market and you know we've seen it
sometimes really
um you know letting us down
um so but it's it it should not be
because of something in the toy safety
directive
um yeah I hope that answers the question
thank you
thank you very much uh I would like to
call you to thank all our panelists and
uh all the speakers and I would like to
inform the members of our imco committee
that uh
your presentations will be published on
official
websites with your consent of course
and once again thank you very much for
this useful debate thank you
and mo I would like to honor to ask
honor to take the floor